so one of the most important solutions
to the global challenge posed by climate
change lies right under our foot every
day its soil soils just a thin veil that
covers the surface of land but it has
the power to shape our planet's destiny
see a six foot or so of soil lose soil
material that covers the Earth's surface
represents the difference between life
and lifelessness in the earth system and
it can also help us combat climate
change if we can only stop treating it
like dirt climate change happening the
Earth's atmosphere is warming because of
increasing amount of greenhouse gases we
keep releasing to the atmosphere you all
know that but what I assume you might
not have heard is that one of the most
important things our human society could
do to address climate change
lies right there in the soil I'm a soil
scientist has been studying soil since I
was 18 because I'm interested in
unlocking the secrets of soil and
helping people understand this really
important climate change solution so
here are the facts about climate the
concentration of carbon dioxide in the
Earth's atmosphere has increased by 40
percent just in the last 150 years or so
human actions are now releasing nine
point four billion metric tons of carbon
to the atmosphere from activities such
as burning fossil fuels and intensive
agricultural practices and other ways we
change the way we use land including
deforestation but the concentration of
carbon dioxide that stays in the
atmosphere is only increasing
by about half of that and that's because
half of the carbon we keep releasing
into the atmosphere is currently being
taken up by land and the seas through a
process we know as carbon sequestration
so in essence whatever consequence you
think will be we're facing from climate
change right now we're only experiencing
the consequence of 50% of our pollution
because the natural ecosystems are
bailing us out but don't get too
comfortable because we have two major
things working against us right now one
unless we do something big and then fast
emissions will continue to rise and
second the ability of these natural
ecosystems to take up carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere and sequestered in
the natural habitats is currently
getting compromised as they're
experiencing serious degradation because
of human actions so it's not entirely
clear that we will continue to get
bailed out by these natural ecosystems
if we continue on this business as usual
path that we've been here's where the
soil comes in there is about 3,000
billion metric tons of carbon in the
soil that's roughly about 315 times the
amount of carbon that we release into
the atmosphere currently and there's
twice more carbon in soil than there is
in vegetation and air think about that
for a second there's more carbon in soil
than there is in all of the world's
vegetation including the lush tropical
rainforests and the giant sequoias the
expensive grasslands
all of the cultivated systems and every
kind of flora you can imagine on the
face of the earth plus all the carbon
that's currently up in the atmosphere
combined and then twice over hence
a very small change in the amount of
carbon stored in soil can make a big
difference in maintenance of the air to
atmosphere but soils not just simply a
storage box for carbon though it
operates more like a bank account and
the amount of carbon that's in soil at
any given time is the function of the
amount of carbon coming in and out of
the soil carbon comes into the soil
through the process of photosynthesis
when green plants take carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere and use it to make
their bodies and upon death their bodies
enter the soil and carbon leaves the
soil and goes right back up into the
atmosphere when the bodies of those
formerly living organisms decay in soil
by activity of microbes see
decomposition releases carbon dioxide
into the atmosphere as well as other
greenhouse gases such as methane and
nitrous oxide but it also releases all
the nutrients we all need to survive one
of the things that makes oil such a
fundamental component of any climate
change mitigation strategy is because it
represents a long-term storage of carbon
carbon that would have lasted maybe a
year or two if in decaying residue if it
was left on the surface can stay in soil
for hundreds of years even thousands and
more soil by a geochemist like me study
exactly how the soil system makes this
possible by locking away the carbon in
physical association with minerals
inside aggregates of soil minerals
information of strong chemical bound
chemical bonds that bind the carbon to
the surfaces of the minerals see when
carbon is entrapped in soil in these
kinds of associations with soil minerals
even the wiliest of the microbes can't
easily degraded and carbon that's not
degrading fast is carbon that's not
going back into the atmosphere as
greenhouse gases but the benefit of
carbon sequestration is not just limited
to climate change
Asian soil that stores large amount of
carbon is healthy fertile soft its
malleable it's workable it's like it
makes it like a sponge and can hold on
to a lot of water and nutrients healthy
and fertile soils like this support the
most dynamic abundant and diverse
habitat for living things that we know
of anywhere in the earth system it's it
makes life possible for everything from
the tiniest of the microbes blood such
as bacteria and fungi all the way to
higher plants and and fulfills the food
feed and fiber needs for all animals
including you and I so at this point you
would assume that we should be treating
soil like the precious resource that it
is unfortunately that's not the case
soil around the world are experiencing
unprecedented rates of degradation
through a variety of human actions that
include deforestation intensive
agricultural production systems over
grazing excessive application of
agricultural chemicals erosion and
similar things half of the world soils
are currently considered degraded soil
degradation is bad for many reasons but
let me just tell you a couple one
degraded soils have diminished potential
to support plant productivity and hence
by degrading soil we're compromising our
own abilities to provide the food and
other resources that we need for us and
every member of living things on the
face of the earth and second soil use
integration just in the last 200 years
or so has released twelve times more
carbon to the atmosphere compared to the
rate at which we're releasing carbon
into the atmosphere right now I'm afraid
there's even more bad news
this is a story of soils of high
latitudes peatlands in polar
environments storm about a third of the
global soil carbon reserves these peat
lands have a permanently frozen ground
underneath the permafrost and the carbon
was able to build up in these soils over
long periods of time because even though
plants are able to photosynthesize
during the short warm summer months the
environment quickly turns cold and dark
and then microbes are not able to
efficiently break down the residue so
the colloidal carbon bank and these
polar environments built up over
hundreds of thousands of years but right
now with atmospheric warming the
permafrost is thawing and draining and
when permafrost thaws and drains it
makes it possible for microbes to come
in and rather quickly decompose all this
carbon with the potential to release
hundreds of billion metric tons of
carbon to the atmosphere in the form of
greenhouse gases and this release of
additional greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere will only contribute to
further warming that makes this
predicament
even worse as it starts a
self-reinforcing positive feedback loop
that could go on and on and on
dramatically changing our climate future
fortunately I can also tell you that
there is a solution for these two wicked
problems of soil degradation and climate
change
just like we created these problems we
do know the solution and the solution
lies and simultaneously working to
address these two things together
through what we call climate smart land
management practices what do I mean here
I mean managing land in a way that's
smart about maximizing how much carbon
we store in soil and we can accomplish
this by putting in place deep-rooted
perennial plants putting back for us
whenever possible
reducing tillage and other disturbance
from agricultural practices including
optimizing the use of agricultural
chemicals and grazing and even adding
carbon to soil whenever possible from
recycled resources such as compost and
even human waste this kind of land
stewardship is not a radical idea it's
what made it possible for fertile soils
to be able to support human
civilizations since time immemorial in
fact some are doing it just right now
there's a global effort underway to
accomplish exactly this goal this effort
that started in France is known as the
for per mil effort and it aims it sets
an aspirational goal to increase the
amount of carbon stored in soil by four
0.4% annually using the same kind of
climate smart land management practices
I mentioned earlier and if this effort
is fully successful it can offset a
third of the global emissions of fossil
fuel derived carbon to the atmosphere
but even if this effort is not fully
successful but we just start heading in
that direction we still end up with
soils that are healthier more fertile
are able to produce all the food and
resources that we need for human
populations and more and also soils that
are better capable of sequestering
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere and
helping with climate change mitigation
I'm pretty sure that's what politicians
call a win-win solution and we all can
have a role to play here we can start by
treating the soil with the respect that
it deserves respect for its ability as
the basis of all life on Earth respect
for its ability to serve as a carbon
bank and respect for its ability to
control our climate and if we do so we
can then simultaneously address
two of the most pressing global
challenges of our time climate change
and soil degradation and in the process
we would be able to provide food and
nutritional security to our growing
human family thank you
[Applause]